the northeast faces a rare tropical
storm threat this morning tropical storm
faye is expected to make landfall in new
york or new jersey later today
cbs news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff baradelli is along the
hudson river in manhattan so jeff what's
going on with this storm
good morning vlad and good morning
everybody so what is going on with this
storm is it's located
that away we are looking south along the
hudson river towards lower manhattan the
clouds are thickening up they are
getting darker
there is a wall of rain about 70 miles
south of here and boy
is it raining heavy along the jersey
shore now this has already made history
this storm is the first
f storm the earliest f storm that we
have seen it's two
uh weeks earlier than the last earliest
f storm
this storm is going to be making its way
up the eastern seaboard producing three
to five inches of rain today and tonight
in places like philly and new york city
flash flooding
is likely tropical storm warnings around
for that area
so watch out it's going to be a rough
and tumble day and night but the bigger
story is a huge
heat dome that is built across the
southwest and the lower plain states
and we are going to see incredibly high
temperatures up to about 120 degrees in
parts of the deep southwest this weekend
some places even higher than that and in
the plains states as we head into sunday
and beyond into early next week
some spots approaching 110 degrees
this is going to be a relentless and
historic heatwave because it's going to
last
very very long and we should get used to
this as we continue to warm the climate
we're going to see more
and more of these heat waves that's
something we want to get used to jeff
thank you very much